For those of you that
were not here on Tuesday.
I just wanted to review a few
introductory comments. Uh,
this is environmental politics and law.
And My name's John Wargo.
I'm a professor of political science as
well as environmental policy, uh, in,
uh, the school of Forestry
and environmental studies,
the Department of Political
Science. And, uh, uh,
I have an appointment in the college,
uh,
for which I chair the
environmental studies major. Uh,
and this course is really designed to
give you an overview of environmental law,
some of its founding, uh,
and key principles, uh,
but also to get you to think more
broadly and deeply about, uh,
our capacity to use law to
shape human behavior. Uh,
and I think that the, uh, the
cases that we'll go through,
we'll largely be a historical cases,
but there'll be designed in a way and
presented in a way to encourage you to
think about evaluating law, uh, to
think about what's worked, what has not,
and why as a way of thinking about how
you might design law for the future.
And the cases that, uh, we'll look at our,
I'm going to concentrate on today and,
uh, these, uh, are,
are a variety that I've had a chance
to work on during my career. Uh,
and the relationship between
law and science will be a
really critical component
of this course. Uh, there are no
prerequisites for the course, uh,
so that you don't have to have training
in chemistry or biology to do well in
the course. But what you'll see is that
scientific uncertainty, uh, especially,
uh,
is really important and how different
groups exploit's scientific uncertainty,
uh,
they choose their own data selectively
to tell their own narratives about what's
worth worrying about it.
So this course is really designed to
get you to think about what's worth
worrying about in a, in a deeper way, uh,
as a way to encourage you to think
about, uh, your own behavior,
but also how you might
encourage others to,
to behave in a more responsible way.
This is not a course in how
to be an environmentalist.
It's a course in how you might think
about defining problems and solving
problems, uh, to, uh,
really help us think about the world
that we're creating a world, uh, uh,
with, uh, many billion more people in
it, uh, given our scarce resources.
So today when I wanted to do was
just to briefly once again a in a,
in about 30 seconds, uh, review, uh,
the obligations of the course
which are to show up. Uh,
it's important to show up.
All of the slides will be posted
on the classes server, uh,
just after the lecture.
And what I'm hoping you'll do is
come to the lecture because a,
you'll see often just images and you
won't know how to interpret those images
and, and uh, via my voice I'll
be interpreting them for you. Uh,
and also the discussion sections
are critical to the course,
so that it's important that you go to
your discussion sections. And I, uh,
I think that all the times of
impulsive, is that correct, Laura?
All the times it will be up on Friday
so that you can make your choices. Uh,
we have eight different sections that
are set up and we're hoping that, uh, uh,
that's sufficient for the class.
There was also the obligation to either
take a midterm paper or conduct a,
a a research effort that would
produce a paper, you know,
roughly 10 to 12 pages in length.
And I'll talk more about that.
And as I lecture all,
I'll often pause and suggest what I think
are interesting research topics, uh,
that,
uh,
will span a whole array of different
kinds of laws and problems that will cover
so that that will be followed at the end
of the chorus by a final examination.
Uh, that, uh, also I'll, I'll
provide a review session for,
and I wanted to make one
thing clear about this.
I made an obligation to give a lecture
at elsewhere, uh, about a year ago, uh,
that, uh, uh, is up at
Dartmouth next Thursday.
So we will not have class next Thursday,
but I will make that up by providing you
with a lecture at the end of the course
and additional lecture,
which will review all the course
material for you prior to the final exam.
So let me start in my
interpretation of the, uh,
the failures and successes of 20th century
environmental law is very much tied
to how problems had been defined.
And if you look back in history,
you'll see that, uh, uh,
problems that have become
immediately apparent have
reached the press. Uh, and a,
a wide public have often
been translated into law.
So if you think about the Cuyahoga River
which used to catch fire routinely in
Ohio,
uh,
used to catch fire because of the
petroleum products that would lie on the
surface of the water,
uh,
that prompted changes in the clean water
act to try to reduce the emissions from
industrial facilities into the rivers.
Uh,
the toxic substance control act,
uh,
evolved after concern about
a variety of, of, uh, uh,
events,
uh,
as well as the resource conservation and
recovery act that applies to hazardous
waste sites.
Following the discovery that a canal
that had been loaded up with toxic
substances in New York state, known as
love canal, had turned into a school site.
Uh, the corporation had basically
abandoned the facility, uh,
and it was turned over to the
community which built a school.
And a gradually this seeping,
oozing a toxic soup started bubbling
to the surface of the playground and
people's backyards and
in into their basements.
And that prompted the passage
of, of the superfund law, uh,
back in the 1980s. So, uh, in,
in many respects a law follows public
recognition of significant threat.
That a is a surprise in a sense.
But these law has evolved
not in a systematic way.
It was not as if somebody said, okay,
we need to, uh, we need air law,
we need a clean water law. Uh, we
need to toxic substance control law.
We have to worry about hazardous sites.
And what about all the federal
land management responsibilities?
How are we going to manage grazing lands?
Timberland's uh, access to minerals.
Uh, how about private development to how
are we going to manage new development,
new subdivisions? Uh, rather than there
being some sort of a comprehensive vision,
uh, about, uh, the nature of law
that was specific saying, okay,
this kind of problems should be dealt
with best at the federal level as opposed
to another kind of problem
should be dealt with by states.
And what about local
governments? Uh, which,
which level of government has
the best capacity to deal with?
Which kind of problem? No one's sat down
and thought comprehensively about this.
And the result is really what
I think of as a, a really a,
a fragmented patchwork quilt that's
quite afraid of various statutes that are
pieced together, uh, that, uh, have
embedded within them different decisions,
standards as well as different
levels of, of funding, uh,
and administered by a variety
of different agencies.
So when I talk about
environmental law, uh, you,
you probably know that the environmental
protection agency has a primary
responsibility to administer
some of the core statutes,
like the Clean Air Act
and the clean water act.
But there are many other statutes
that deal with the chemicals in the
environment, uh, that, uh,
give authority to groups like
the food and Drug Administration,
the Consumer Product Safety
Commission as, as examples. Uh,
and often responsibility for one
kind of a problem. Uh, and we'll,
we'll see this particularly
with respect to pesticides,
is fractured among different agencies
with responsibility to implement.
So the Department of Agriculture
has a responsibility to,
to consider the benefits and costs of
farmers of new pesticide regulations.
EPA has a responsibility to look at
toxicity data for pesticides and to judge
what the risk is and to set the standards.
The Food and Drug Administration has
the responsibility to go out and monitor
what's in the food supply.
So we know whether or not people are
being exposed to dangerous stuff, uh,
chemical residues. So does this make
sense? That absolutely does not.
And then when we get to
the pesticide case, I'll,
I'll tell you a story about how I
tried to pull data together from the
Department of Agriculture, uh, on what
people eat, uh, pull data together on a,
from the food and Drug Administration.
About what residues they
found in those foods.
Pull data from the
environmental protection agency
together in a way that made
sense to try to figure out what you or
an individual might be exposed to and
what your risk might be. Uh, the databases
were all set up in different formats,
uh,
using different software.
It was a nightmare and it took about
three years to integrate the data sets in
order to answer the simple question,
what are people exposed to?
So the patchwork quilt that's frayed
that offers insufficient protection is a,
is a key image that I want you to
carry with you. How we define problems,
uh, often, uh, will result in,
in, uh, the effectiveness of, of,
of the solution. And often the problems
had been a highly reductionist, uh,
in their definition. And this is, uh, uh,
also been associated with their
assignment to specific agencies.
And we'll see that many of
these problems cross, uh,
many different boundaries and a,
the absence of thinking in a systems
way or thinking ecologically lies at,
at, uh, uh, the core of the issue.
So what are the central questions
of environmental law? Uh,
one is the level of government that's
appropriate to the problem. Clearly,
if you have air pollution blowing across
state boundaries and local boundaries,
uh, if everybody sets their
own, every state sets their
own, uh, air pollution law,
uh, that's going to be a
nightmare. Everybody has their own,
each state has their own standard.
Uh,
another key question would be what branch
of government I should establish the
law? Uh, so should it be the, uh, uh,
Congress or should it be
the executive branch? Uh,
so EPA has the authority to set
regulations, so congress passes a statute,
sets out broad guidelines,
and then the environmental protection
agency has the authority to set
regulations that,
uh,
really are more refined and dependent
upon the scientific evidence.
So you really wouldn't want Congress to
get involved in the setting of highly
specific regulations, uh, that, uh, uh,
really would demand and understanding
of the technical details.
What's our capacity to detect
this chemical? Uh, what's
our capacity to, uh, uh,
understand it's risk?
Who's most at threat?
What are the costs and benefits
associated with regulation?
Do we really want Congress to deal
with that kind of specificity.
And I think often not, therefore
the executive branch, uh,
meaning the Environmental Protection
Agency or other regulatory agencies are
often given that authority when
they're given that authority. Uh,
and they don't do anything about it.
Ha as has been the case for
many of these problems. Uh,
Congress often we'll call them up and
hold hearings and, and demand, uh,
them to explain why nothing
has been accomplished.
And we'll talk about the safe drinking
water act is a great example of that
where Congress finally threw
up his hands and said, uh, EPA,
you're just not doing your job and we
are going to specify which chemicals you
have got to test for in drinking water.
And you have got to set maximum
contaminant levels for those chemicals and
drinking water and you've
got to do it by date x.
Or they did that also with the hazardous
chemicals law so that Congress does get
upset. Regulations can be
passed by the president, uh,
via executive order.
And also the judiciary plays a really
critical role so that the, the, uh,
collection of decisions surrounding any
one of these problems creates precedent
for future decisions.
Uh,
and courts are often in a position of
interpreting uncertainty in the language
of statutes,
but also uncertainty in the,
in the language of regulations. And there
are highly individualized cases. Um,
and, uh, unfortunately the,
uh, uh, uh, process of,
of adjudication in the court system
is not a very close to the process of
discovering new knowledge
that, uh, we think about here
within the academy. Uh, it,
it's not about discovering truth.
It's not about proving causality. Uh,
it's about control of evidence to tell
a story. So, uh, the courts really are,
are, uh, uh, looking at competing
narratives of what the problem is,
what the damage is and whether
or not the defendant, uh,
really is responsible for
adversely affecting the plaintiffs.
So another key question is
monitoring and surveillance.
And it's very easy to pass a law that it
sounds great on, on, uh, uh, on its face.
Uh,
but if you look at it really carefully,
what you'll find is that there's really
no comprehension of how much monitoring
and surveillance is required in order to
really do the job to get the job done.
So monitoring and surveillance,
I think of as one of the primary
defects of 20th century law. Uh,
so we have grossly
misunderstood the amount of,
of money that it will take to really
figure out what happens when you release a
chemical to the environment.
What happens if you blow it out of your
tailpipe on your car or it comes out of
a, uh, uh, a, a nuclear power plant or
radio new cloud goes up into the air.
What happens to that to figure that out
is extremely expensive and a in society
with respect to air
pollution, law, chemical law,
even endangered species management,
understanding how many
individuals of both sexes, of,
uh, uh, of endangered mammals
exist, where they are,
what their reproductive rate is.
That takes intensive monitoring.
So when these laws are passed,
if the government does not set up a
really effective and efficient monitoring
and surveillance program, the whole thing
is just like a waste of time. So, uh,
the, the, uh, uh, level of,
of misunderstanding of this issue, I
just cannot, I cannot emphasize enough.
Uh, another key question is access to
data. So who should have access to date?
And I'll give you a good example of this.
I'm working on a project
now and I'm working,
it happens to do with green building
standards and I was wondering about a
carpet treatments and uh, the, uh, uh,
stain master carpets as an example.
Everybody's heard of stain master.
Other,
other chemicals are applied
to the surface of carpets, uh,
to keep them from absorbing stains or
to keep things from sticking to them.
Uh, so, uh, you might think about
to cook, whereas another example,
a lot of cookware now, you don't
have to put any sort of, uh, uh,
an oil into it in order to keep things
from sticking in it. So the, the,
the chemicals that are used to
accomplish this, including to make your,
your clothing waterproof.
Uh, for example, uh, uh,
I was skiing last week and I looked down
at myself and I said, boy, you know,
I thought this was just a, you know, a
nice waterproof shell that I was wearing.
And then I started thinking,
oh, you idiot, you know,
you, you're, you're, uh, uh,
wearing a product and you have
no idea what the ingredient is.
And I'm reading reports
saying that everybody,
almost everybody has
this chemical in their,
in their body and detectable in their
human tissue. So all of a sudden the chem,
now think about this history. The
chemical is released into the marketplace.
It get you,
it gets used in nonstick pans.
It gets used to be sprayed on the
carpets to keep, uh, you know,
red wine from absorbing to the,
to the fiber.
It gets sprayed on surfaces such
as clothing to keep people dry. Uh,
so that the functionality has been the
primary concern. Nobody asks the question,
what happens to this chemical? Then down
the road somebody says, well, let's test,
let's test blood,
or let's test urine and let's test a
body fat or maybe even here to figure out
where this thing is going and whether
or not it's there and they find,
Lo and behold, it is there. And then, uh,
to try to get the chemical
out of the marketplace,
which is now global is a very
difficult thing to accomplish.
So, access to data, uh, I'm reading
this report about this data and the, uh,
one of the major corporations,
uh, dupont, uh, is, is,
has been producing chemicals
that, uh, have this, this effect.
And they submitted a report to EPA,
EPA put it up online. And I, I've,
I've got to show it to you. Uh, I
haven't gotten it up in a pdf format yet,
but I've got to show it
to you because every,
every page has the title of the topic.
Uh,
and then it has CBI written on
it with nothing else. CBI is,
uh, the acronym for confidential
business information.
So the information was submitted to from
dupont to the environmental protection
agency and the environmental protection
agency basically shuts down the public
from understanding what
that is. Uh, and it's,
it's all about how much of
the chemical is produced,
what the company knows
about, where it goes, uh,
and also what the health effects
or environmental effects might be.
So access to data, intellectual property
rights, a secrecy and confidentiality.
These are all things that we really
need to think about very carefully, uh,
when we structure environmental law.
Another key question number five is,
should we allow preemption?
Preemption is a really
interesting idea that, uh,
on the federal government could prevent
a state from adopting regulations that
might be different or less restrictive
than the federal standards. And the,
the clean air act is a great example
of this because the clean air act does
preempt states from adopting regulations
that are different from the federal
standards with respect to vehicle
emissions, power plant emissions,
a mercury emissions, and the
state of California. However,
it was exempted by Congress when that
statute was passed. And why is that? Well,
it's because they have some pretty
severe air quality problems.
There are different patches in the country
where air quality is very, very poor.
And one is the La Basin and other
is the, uh, Salt Lake basin. Uh,
and uh, Houston, Atlanta,
Chicago, New York.
This area is out of compliance with
clean air act standards quite routinely.
And you might think that a,
this geographic and,
and climatological variability is a pretty
good justification for states to have
the capacity,
the legal capacity to set their own laws.
So the states have far higher
pollution than the national average.
So that, uh, thinking about,
uh, what kinds of problems, uh,
are amenable to,
uh,
having states have more authority as
opposed to when do we want to centralize
authority across all
states in, in, and locate,
locate the authority with
the federal government.
This is a really important question.
Another key question is administrative
discretion versus statutory criteria. Uh,
so when should congress give the
environmental protection agency the
administrative discretion,
uh, to set standards, uh,
to judge whether or not
the economic benefits are,
are outweighing what the
environmental harm might be. A,
should they have the authority to do that.
So if you,
if you adopt a utilitarian standard
that's cost benefit balancing or say risk
benefit balancing,
uh,
then you're basically giving the
agency a lot of discretion to do their
technical analysis and to try to figure
out how to go through that balancing act
that gives them a lot of authority,
uh,
as opposed to setting statutory criteria
saying the risk shall not be greater
than x.
Say cancer risks should not be greater
than one in a million or the decision
standard within the, the Food
Quality Protection Act, uh,
that the agency must, uh, uh, find, uh,
a reasonable certainty that no harm
will result from any pesticide.
Sounds unfortunate. So thinking about, uh,
whether or not it makes sense to, to,
uh, give an administrative agency,
that kind of discretion, uh, is very
important. And it depends again,
on the technical nature of the problem.
Another key question is risk averaging.
Uh, if you have lousy data, uh,
data that, uh, uh, is collected, uh,
maybe with very small sample sizes, uh,
so that you have no understanding of
democratic variability and exposure. Uh,
or in the, uh, the, the,
the complex temporal and spacial
distributional patterns of pollution.
Uh, then it's like looking at the world
without my glasses on, which is, uh, uh,
you know, all, all of the students
look the same. Uh, so that, uh,
you lose any resolution,
uh,
you lose the ability to
identify pockets of a,
a serious problems or high
risk or high exposure. Uh,
and if you don't have that
resolution in your data,
you can't go in and protect
the most vulnerable. Those
people that are, are, uh,
are most at risk.
So if,
if a EPA does not have a good
monitoring and surveillance data,
they get to a position statistically
where they're forced to to average very
broadly, uh, across space, across
time and across demographic groups.
And, and this is a very
serious problem getting, uh,
getting our system of
environmental law to have the,
the scientific and evidentiary
foundation that allows the analyst to
discriminate between, uh, you know,
what's a really clean area and
what's a really dirty area.
And I'll give you one example of that.
We'll,
that we'll look at later in the term
with respect to vehicle emissions. Uh,
I wondered about this because EPA sets
their air quality monitoring out in
fields.
There's one just across the cube bridge
on interstate 95 right next to the
highway. When you go across, you get
to the other side of the bridge. Uh,
if you're heading east on 95, you can
see it set up on a little platform. Uh,
so that's a fixed monitoring site where
they're measuring particulate matter,
they're measuring ozone occasionally,
very occasionally they measure voc. Uh,
so that, that, uh, uh,
their image of the distribution of air
pollution in the nation comes from this
network of fixed stations and they've
got probably two dozen set up in
Connecticut.
Well,
I wondering whether or not you would
come to a very different conclusion about
the quality of air in the
movement of pollution, uh,
particularly vehicle emissions and the
carbon particles I was talking about on
Tuesday. If instead of a reading
your data coming from the stations,
you put the monitors on kids and you
followed them through their daily life.
And the answer is of
course it's different.
It's radically different and I'll
demonstrate in a few weeks why that is.
So EPA has this image of,
of uh,
pollution being quite uniform across
the state, uh, or across a region. Uh,
whereas the pollution that you inhale a
on a daily basis coming from secondhand
cigarette smoke or firsthand
cigarette smoke, uh,
coming from a vehicle emissions coming
from power plant emissions of power
plants in Ohio, uh, generally it takes,
it takes about two weeks
for particles released, uh,
to the air in Europe if they're very
fine to make it into the stratosphere and
to go all the way around the world and
then come back and become part of our
climate. Uh, so that, uh, it's
very interesting that, that uh, uh,
your image of,
of,
of what's worth worrying about is very
dependent upon this monitoring and
sampling and how specific it is.
Number eight is really critical.
The burden of proof and
the standard of proof.
Who should bear the burden
of proof that that a,
a problem is really serious?
Well,
industry often claims that it's
the public's responsibility
to demonstrate that
their emissions, uh, their
chemicals, they're harvesting
of a national forest, uh,
that, uh, that is creating a problem.
So if this burden lies on a, uh,
an impoverished community, uh,
or it lies on a group of a,
of families in a small neighborhood,
they're not going to be able to mount this
scientific analysis and, and, and, uh,
develop the funding, uh,
to mount a legal, uh,
to, to challenge industry standards.
Most large corporations have, have,
uh, groups of lawyers.
They have a large, uh,
offices of lawyers or they hire
law firms to represent them.
I've been involved in litigation for
the past two decades, uh, and, uh,
sat across the table from a six lawyers,
from a major chemical company,
uh, being deposed on a
number of occasions. Uh,
and this was just a very
small group of lawyers that,
that we're trying to pick apart.
You know, my claim, uh, that, uh,
chemical posed as a specific
threat to children. Uh, so most,
uh, plaintiffs would not have the capacity
to mount that kind of legal expertise.
And don't forget this basic,
this basic idea that probably 90%,
even 95% of of environmental science of
health science relative to environmental
quality. Uh, what sector
does that go on in?
It doesn't go on in the public sector.
It goes on in the private sector, uh,
so that, uh, corporations that are, are
very interested in, in making a profit,
uh, and selling goods and services. Uh,
they basically are doing their
own internal risk assessments, uh,
for what the effect might be on, on,
uh, the environment or human health. Uh,
and those can never see the light of day.
I'll talk in the pesticide case in
a few weeks about a one compound.
It's an organophosphate insecticide and
one of the world's most heavily used and,
uh, uh, via litigation. Uh,
the group I work with, uh,
uh, forced disclosure of,
of a database that, uh, uh,
who was really pray quite remarkable.
Uh,
this company had spent $100 million,
uh,
on studies for one chemical to keep
it in the marketplace so they could
understand what its risks might be.
Uh, now, uh, that's quite impressive.
Uh, so think about challenging,
uh, the quality of that evidence.
Another company submitted a, a, uh,
a proposal to the environmental protection
agency to continue their license to
use a pesticide. Uh, this happened
to be an herbicide known as atrazine.
Atrazine is found in the wells of about
30 million people in the Midwest right
now, uh, because it's sprayed across the
landscape planted with corn and soybeans.
Uh, it's a, uh, an endocrine disruptor.
In other words, it's hormonally active.
Uh, and also, uh, it's believed
to pose different kinds of
threats to human health.
So when,
uh,
when this corporation decided that
it wanted to submit it to data to the
environmental protection agency, they
decided to do it, uh, not electronically,
but to deliver the material
and to deliver the material.
It took them two tractor trailer loads
a of boxes with a datasets and the
supporting evidence,
which they drove up to the docks of
the environmental protection agency in.
And so you can imagine this,
a regulatory office of EPA looking at
this huge sea of boxes that they would
have to analyze. That's a very interesting
strategy. And so what would that do?
Well,
it basically would put a regulatory effort
that might be chugging down the road
at a good pace and it would
put it in the deep freeze.
It would slow it down to the point where,
oh my gosh,
this agency has to look at a thousand
chemicals. This is one chemical,
and we've got to go through all those
data sets and we're going to have to
understand whether or not that evidence
really is supportable, credible,
replicable, oh, that's going
to slow things down, one
out of a thousand chemicals.
So, uh, the burden of proof, the standard
of proof is a really critical issue.
So for civil actions, uh, you, you
need to remember, uh, that, uh, uh,
the, the plaintiff, uh, needs to
demonstrate that, uh, damage occurred,
uh,
not beyond a reasonable doubt,
but by the standard of preponderance
of the evidence. In other words,
it's more likely than not that
the defendant caused the damage.
Think about that with respect to
the standard of proof required.
If you wanted to submit a paper to
science magazine, well, you know,
you'd be asked questions about, uh, okay,
what's your confidence interval? Uh,
do you have a 95% confidence, uh, in,
in the a causal relationship that
you're, you're, uh, uh, hypothesizing,
uh, or is it a 99% confidence? Uh,
so that the standard of proof that that
is applied before a decision is made is
a critical issue. And this can be
adjusted if you're designing law.
Also national sovereignty to
re regulate to foreign hazards.
There are a variety of international
standards set up to prevent the,
the export of,
of hazardous waste.
So there's quite a controversy brewing
right now about electronic waste being
transmitted, particularly to
an Asian nations, which are,
are trying to recycle the precious
metals out of computer equipment,
uh, old cell phones. Uh, and, uh,
even though there may be
only a 75 cents per, per, uh,
uh, cell phone in terms of the value of,
of those metals, uh, there are some, uh,
three dozen different metals that can be
extracted from electronic equipment and
a, if they're thrown away
or if they're burned,
the material will go up
into the atmosphere or it
will make its way down into
the soil and the groundwater. Uh, and
also the people that are doing this,
the people that are burning the plastic
off of the electronic components in the
metals,
they are often exposed at a high level.
So that's a very interesting problem.
How could we regulate international trade?
Well, this issue of national sovereignty
is very important. Does one nation,
one another nation telling it what it
can and cannot import a, does it want to,
uh, uh, uh, demand that,
that nation adopt some sort
of a universal standard?
And the answer is clearly
no. Uh, and finally, uh,
what criteria would we use to choose
among the possible legal strategies,
uh, that, uh, are there?
So I'm going to skip a really quickly now,
uh,
to a variety of different cases. And, uh,
I'd like you to imagine a society with
no environmental law. And by the way,
that was the United States back in
1950 when we had no clean air act,
no clean water act.
Uh,
and how would you design law
in order to assure a healthy,
productive and sustainable future?
That is a central question that I hope
you can address by the end of the course.
Now,
imagine a society in the year 2010 as we
sit here where our law is fractured by
problem and by media. Uh, so
by media I need air, water,
food, or by problem type. Hazardous
wastes are hazardous sites or,
or a pesticide problem. It's
fractured by level of government. Uh,
there's very little surveillance.
It tends to evolve at a snail's pace.
And a little anecdote there,
uh, in, in a variety of, uh,
decisions to,
uh,
regulate or license an individual
chemical or a new product. Uh,
it often will take EPA,
uh,
up to a decade or 15 years to go through
a review to determine whether or not,
uh, that chemical is safe. Whether
or not poses excessive risk, uh,
or what the economic benefit is if it's a,
if it's being reviewed under a balancing
and cost standard. So that, uh,
uh,
now imagine this out of the
80,000 chemicals that are
out there in international
commerce,
if it takes EPA 15 years
to review one chemical,
what does that tell you about what their
capacity is to manage your exposure to
dangerous things?
It tells you what's exceptionally limited.
Our system of law also provides a false
sense of security because most of us
believe that, uh, the, the, uh,
the little statements on the back of,
uh, uh, different products such as,
uh,
a nervous side and the hardware
store that says this is EPA license.
That's almost a certification of
safety in most people's minds.
Many people think it wouldn't be in
the marketplace if it was dangerous.
People have reviewed this,
right? Well, you know,
by the time you're finished
with this course, you will,
you will be thinking, uh,
uh, quite a, quite a
lot about that problem.
So environmental law is also highly
specialized in the sciences and as I just
said, about 95% of environmental
science goes on in the private sector.
Uh, and what that means is that,
uh, they have a, a a a leg up.
They have a competitive advantage and
controlling the narrative about the nature
of the danger. So that,
uh, thinking about, uh,
how to set up an institution that really
would produce science that would be
publicly available, that
would be, uh, transparent.
It would be open,
the data would be out there.
So you or I could review it. I mean,
that's a, that's a big obligation.
Uh, it's also highly politicized
and its implementation. Uh,
there are all sorts of stories about,
uh,
regulators in inside the
food and Drug Administration,
occupational safety and
Health Administration and
the Environmental Protection
Agency and how they move at fairly
high levels from the agency,
assistant administrator for
toxic substances and EPA
going to work for Monsanto.
A, they'll go to work for
Monsanto, uh, during periods of,
of, uh, uh, liberal administration,
and then they'll come back
into the administration, uh,
during periods of conservative
administrations. So that, uh,
there's this revolving door
idea among top regulators.
It's extremely difficult
to regularly, uh, also, uh,
our system of law is very poorly
supported by the nonprofit community.
You may think that there's a large network
of, of nonprofits out there that are,
are playing the watchdog role. Uh,
but, but you're wrong. In fact, uh,
when the area of the
Safe Drinking Water Act,
there is no nonprofit in Washington DC
that has taken the safe drinking water
act under, it's under its purview
saying, this is our specialty,
but you can always count on them
to be there to, uh, to, uh, uh,
try to judge the reasonableness
of a proposed regulation.
Uh, generally, uh,
in the system of environmental
law that we've got is utilitarian.
It's balancing of costs
and benefits or risks are,
or the estimate of damages and a
with economic benefits might be,
and inherent in that decision
standard is this problem.
You've got costs that are
pretty easy to quantify.
And if you've got a firm
that's making a product,
they're going to tell you with pretty good
accuracy, their opinion about, uh, what,
what they would lose if you
took that right away from
them to Bruce that product.
Uh, now by contrast,
if you think about, uh,
the damage side of the equation
or the risk side of the equation,
that's a projection that's a
projection out into the future.
Uh, that's a probabilistic estimate
of what might happen into the future.
And the global warming, a transformation
in thinking that we've, we've, uh,
we've seen over the past decade has really
been quite remarkable because people
are thinking now,
uh,
out over a long time horizon in ways
that they never had before. You know,
what is it climate going to be like and
what's it going to do two or ecosystems
and to our, our, our shorelines into our
health a hundred years down the road.
There were very few people that think
out in that long term. So how do you,
how do you project damages out
over long periods of time? Well,
you rely on very complex computer models
to do that so that you have to have
faith in those who are
doing the projection and the
quality of the analysis so
that, uh, uh,
this problem can be kind of capsulized
in the idea that costs are often
relatively well known and they can be
projected with relative precision over the
short term compared to, uh, the harms,
the environmental and health harms that
are highly uncertain and they're often
projected way out into the future with a
really fuzzy image of how they're going
to fall out differently
on different groups. Uh,
also our system of law, environmental
law has been trivialized, I think, uh,
by, uh, the concerns that we have over
international security and terrorism.
Basically nobody was talking about
environmental law for several years, uh,
between 2001, uh, following the,
uh, the attack on the trade centers,
uh, in 2004, 2005, uh,
environmental law came back to life.
But even when the public is, is asked,
you know,
what do you care about most in terms of
problems that the United States faces?
You will see issues such as the economy
regularly being first on that list,
you'll see issues of national security
being in the top two or three. Uh,
but people are thinking in a,
in a much, uh, about, uh, uh,
very different collection of problems
rather than, than environmental concern.
We'll be talking about the importance
of public perception of the environment
compared to these other social
objectives in the future. Uh,
one other point I wanted to make is that
the, the estimates today are that, uh,
the system that we have in place now
costs industry about 300 to $400 billion
per year in the United States alone,
uh,
only in compliance costs.
That's pretty remarkable. Uh,
EPA and other groups have reviewed
this estimate along with the government
accountability office. Uh, that's
a, that's a very large investment.
So put the pieces together here
of what I've just told you.
I've told you that we have this system
of law that is not working very well, uh,
for a whole variety of reasons.
Now I'm telling you that this is costing
society an enormous amount of money.
Well. Uh, does that make sense? We'll,
we'll come back to that issue. Uh,
during the term now I'm going to spend
about 10 minutes just quickly reviewing
some of the cases that we'll go through
that we'll demonstrate some of these,
these key principles.
1955 was a 1954 was a turning point
for environmental ism in the nation,
in the world because it basically taught
people to think at a global scale about
nature and about the environment
for the very first time.
And it's the result of this explosion
on the Bikini atoll in the Marshall
Islands that punched up radioactive
material into the stratosphere.
And at the time they thought that, well,
we had to worry about where it would,
where it would go, how it
would be distributed, uh,
within a couple of hundred miles.
And a variety of mistakes were made,
including, uh, uh, exposing
people working for the military.
Uh, this group of people was, uh, uh,
sitting in these lawn chairs and their
shorts and, uh, uh, their caps on,
they had ski goggles on. You know,
with a dark lens is thinking,
well that would be safe enough.
Or there are many,
many stories about workers being exposed,
uh,
beyond what normal normally we would
think of as, as being a safe level today.
So what you don't know can hurt you.
And the more you ask about
a chemical movement, the,
the more we recognize that a chemical is
actually persist longer than we thought
they would. Uh, they often move further
in ways that were non intuitive,
uh, through ecosystems, marine
food chains, uh, they, they, uh,
may get deposited in the
landscape in different ways.
We'll see next week when we take
this story apart, uh, that, uh,
one of the major surprises was that this
material got into global circulation,
uh,
so that everybody in the world was exposed
to radionuclides strontium 90 iodine,
one 31, CCM, one 37 a.
And your parents were all are all walking
around today with those byproducts
that often have halflife so thousands
of years. So that, uh, these are,
these are really important lessons.
The atomic energy commission
figured this out by 1955, 1956,
they figured out that, uh, these,
these radionuclides wouldn't just
kind of go away. And that's been a,
that's been the perception of most
people about chemicals released to the
environment. They just go away.
Uh, many of them don't go away, uh,
particularly radionuclides and,
uh, they move around the world. Uh,
they tend to settle down. The heavier
particles will settle down. Uh,
when it's dry,
the finer particles tend to aggregate.
And then when a rain cloud intersects
with, with the dust cloud, uh,
as they settled down into lower
elements of the atmosphere,
that's when they rain down into the earth.
And that creates a patchy pattern of
contamination. It's a patchy pattern,
but we can figure out what the deposition
deposition rates were 50 years ago
today, just by taking soil samples.
It's very interesting. So that a,
you can back calculate the halflife
of CCM one 37 or strontium 90,
and you see that it actually plays out,
excuse me,
in a very patchy way
that is dependent upon this intersection
between the dust cloud and the rain
clouds.
So the number one failure that we'll see
as we go through this case is a failure
of systems thinking,
a failure to think ecologically.
But the atomic energy
commission was clearly thinking
ecologically back in 1955.
Uh, but then we, we've been waking
up over the past 50, 60 years
without really paying much attention
to this story. So that, uh,
we'll see as the milk was tested,
uh,
in the ground,
soil contamination levels of strontium
90 were tested between the period of 54
and in 1958 when a more atomic
bombs were exploded than in,
during any other period in human
history. Uh, you see this correlation,
this rise in levels and the
soil and levels in the milk.
And then you see the levels in the human
diet going up during the same period of
time and the levels and human bone.
They didn't know that.
They didn't know that at the time. They
designed the bombs, uh, so that, uh,
they didn't know that strontium 90 would
compete with calcium, uh, to, to, uh, uh,
be fixed within bone in the
human body. Uh, but the, the, uh,
atomic energy commission created this
clan to Stein operation where they
collected dead bodies from 15,000
people around the world, uh,
and they sent them to the labs
in Chicago, uh, and to, uh,
to Lamont Laboratory and,
uh,
to Columbia University
where they were tested. Uh,
and every bone they tested
found strontium 90 in it.
And that really woke them up.
You can find this story only because
this documentation that was formerly
classified for the, uh, until
the mid to late 1990s, uh,
is now available in the
declassified documents database.
It's really a fascinating story.
These people were sitting around in the
Atomic Energy Commission is headquarters
actually saying, well, you know,
what is the law and body snatching?
They use that phrase body snatching.
Where are we going to get cadavers?
Do we really have to ask relatives about
this? Well, what about homeless people?
Uh,
so the atomic energy commission was
collecting bones from around the world and
they were able to build this map of
the deposition rate of strontium 90,
uh, by, uh,
looking at bones that came from Argentina
bones that came from South Africa.
And I can just imagine what their faces
look like when they saw the levels, uh,
that, uh, we're spanning all attitudes
and basically all nations in the world.
Well, this story gets repeated. It
gets repeated chemical by chemical. Uh,
as EPA begins to come to life
in the 1970s and eighties,
begins to wake up in this case to
polybrominated diphenyl ethers, uh, that,
uh, uh, are these flame retardants, uh,
that we now all walk around with.
And it's a common story that we,
we first find the chemicals in wildlife.
Why? Because they're easy to test on.
People generally don't like to give
bone samples so that, uh, uh, their,
their bones can be tested
for strontium 90. By the way,
there's an interesting kind of way to
figure out what's in your bone by testing
teeth. Uh, so by testing the
deciduous teeth of young kids, uh,
the atomic energy commission figured
this out and they were actually going
around from Dennis to Dennis collecting
teeth from people thinking, well,
you know,
why were we crazy enough to
have to collect bones from
dead people when we could
have just collected teeth?
So you find that you find this pattern
of recognition first and wildlife.
Then they say, oh, well I know how,
how did it get into the wildlife?
And then gradually somebody said,
boy, if it's in the wildlife,
it might be in humans too.
Uh, and gradually people
started testing breast milk.
Breast milk became the, the tissue
of choice in order to, to, uh, uh,
understand whether or not
chemicals were being transmitted.
Transgenerationally and it also is,
it's easy to collect,
uh, it, uh, is relatively
inexpensive to store.
And here's a good example of DDT found
in different nations around the world in
breast milk in the 1970s.
So human tissue testing became really
an important way to figure out, uh,
what people were,
were exposed to.
And if you know that you
find it in somebody's body,
then you have this kind of
interesting problem. Well,
how do I figure out where I encountered
it? How, how was I exposed it?
I breathe it to eat it and the
food to come in the drinking water.
So these are all questions that EPA
has faced on numerous occasions. Uh,
this is the island of the
case that we'll spend a,
a lecture on or two in a few weeks where
I've worked for a couple of years and
I've worked on hazardous,
uh,
defense sites and the process of
their restoration for, for, uh, uh,
sites in, in Massachusetts, uh, sites
in California as well as sites in,
in Puerto Rico. And this is a
fascinating story, uh, that, uh,
led me to understand how chemicals
moved through the food chain. And a,
this is a bombing run.
200 million pounds of bombs were
dropped on this little island, uh,
over the period between 1940 and 1919.
Uh,
uh,
or actually 2003.
So I wondered where did the
chemicals in those bombs go?
So I took students some from this
class down and we dove in this bay.
Uh, we found a, a, an old destroyer.
We found 2000 pound bombs that were as
long as this stage and about that wide
lying, underwater rusting out, leaking.
We found mounds of artillery shells.
Uh, I remember one case where I was,
uh, my goggles had fogged up and I came
to the surface and like looked around and
looked and saw there was a tank on the,
on a hill that was only about
20 meters from where I was.
And then I cleared my goggles and I looked
down and I was within about two feet
standing on a pile of,
of artillery shells.
And I hadn't really put
two and two together. Uh,
but destroyers had sat
offshore and for 30, 40 years,
we're lobbying,
uh,
these artillery shells at the tank
on the hill for target practice.
And a bunch of them had missed,
uh, and piled up in the same place.
So they're still sitting there. I
mean, I could take, uh, take you there.
Now we can still see the 2000 palm bumps.
So the,
the base closure and
reclamation act, uh, back, uh,
that that was established.
It's closing down a bunch of these
bases has led the army, the air force,
the Navy, uh, uh, to
basically close basis,
walk away and uh,
clean up according to standards
that they believe are safe.
So this will be a story about standard
setting that turns into a story about
chemicals moving in, in the marine food
chain. You've heard about mercury in tuna,
you probably heard about mercury
in shark in large predatory fish,
but you probably haven't heard about
mercury in the array of tropical fish, uh,
that, uh, exist in, in,
uh, uh, uh, the sees,
well, that's because they haven't been
studied. People tend to look at, uh,
at the chemicals and the larger
fish, they tend to avoid, uh, the,
the study of, of uh, uh,
this set of tropical fish,
uh,
because these don't comprise them at
large proportion of the u s average diet,
uh, or other high income nations that
would fund this kind of research, uh,
would not comprise their, their diet. So
the problem I faced in Puerto Rico is,
wow, you know, uh, I know that these
people eat a lot of these fish. Um,
and there were probably two dozen
that they eat on a routine basis. Uh,
what happens to a TNT HDX,
which are explosives?
What happens to cadmium and mercury
and lead and aluminum and copper in a
variety of other chemicals that
are components of munitions, uh,
how do they build up in fish? And is
this population more exposed than others?
So that island communities,
whether it's the Marshall Islanders,
the Seychelle Islanders,
the, uh, via Kenzie, uh,
that had these diets that
are very rich in fish,
they can be more exposed than others.
So I'm going to jump ahead here because
I'm running out of time and I'll come
back to these, uh, and
get to the final slide.
Oh, I see. How much fun
we're going to have.
Want to leave you today with one image
that was up in the Wasatch, uh, last week.
I spent eight days, eight
days in heaven, so to speak.
And if any of you have not been to the
Wasatch, I encourage you to go there.
This is just east of Salt Lake City,
about 10,000 feet in height and a
standing there looking out at these
magnificent mountains. Uh, I
suddenly realized, you know,
given what I've told you today,
chemical movement through the atmosphere,
through the environment, you suddenly
realize that the idea of wildness,
the idea of purity,
the idea of environmental quality that
most people have and most people value.
Uh, it's really being challenged by the
way we're using and abusing chemicals so
that, uh, the failure of law to
effectively control these chemicals,
uh,
terrain down in the snows and the Wasatch
to get into the bodies of different
species of wildlife into the plants
and the animals or the humans that are
drinking the water. The failure
to control that is challenging.
Our very sense of what wildness is
of what purity is of what nature is.
So I'm going to close there and
leave you with a sense of challenge,
uh, that, uh, we need to think
about a different system.
We need to think about a different way.
For a lot of work that could prevent
this from continuing through future
generations. Okay. That's
it for today. Thank you.